[Music]  celebrities still furious that hundreds  of their private photos were leaked  online yesterday we showed you some new  celebrity photos that were hacked that  was irresponsible but that was yesterday  today I'm sorry to report even more  embarrassing photos have surfaced really  embarrassing photos these might be the  most damaging yet let's take a look  Angelina Jolie really embarrassed about  this photo of her trying to return an  orphan people unhappy about that yeah  here's a hacked photo of Pope Francis at  an Insane Clown Posse concert here's  Bruce Jenner leaving his favorite store  and here's another hack photo it's  grumpy cat looking happy that could ruin  him  finally it's Daft Punk with their  helmets off this could ruin those guys  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you